Say I'm trying to build a game that
let's people build their own robots but
I'm not sure what I want
the icon to look like.
Let's consider these three options for
an icon and decide on a best design.
Our first choice,
is a picture of nuts and
bolts that says robot on it and
this one is not very good.
I don't think I'd be able to read
the label if it gets any smaller,
like if it's displayed on my phone.
And the colors aren't very eye catching.
The second is a picture of a large R.
This one is readable and
has a nice bold green background but
it doesn't really tell me
what the game's about.
Labels like this work for established
brands, think of the Facebook F but
otherwise, a person browsing
will more want more information.
And the last option is, a picture of a
robot with the screw going in his head.
It's colorful and descriptive.
We immediately know that the game Is
about robots, and there's no small text.
So, this looks like the best choice.
The next thing a person will see
in the app store after your icon,
is the game screenshots and description.
So, let's learn more about these next.